and we here and we ready let's go
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to
yo absolutely
favorite podcast
[Music]
welcome back
[Music]
what's up y'all welcome back and we once
again we live in full effect
had a busy weekend so i couldn't get
this podcast done so i'm always ready to
do it live i actually like doing it live
you know it's fun so welcome back today
i'm going to talk about the olympics a
little bit
i got a movie review of luca the movie
luca i saw that on disney with rachel
and um of course real world advice from
a grown ass man and i'll even take some
live in the chat but once again
everybody welcome back to
[Music]
yes riffing with griffin back in the
house live
in full effect thank you for being here
everybody um but you know but first
before we even uh go on uh uh with the
show
i wanna say hello to our new sponsor
you know new old sponsor really uh
support for riverfront girlfriend is
brought to you by
manscaped who is the best in man
men's below the waste grooming champions
of the world manscape
offers precision engineered tools for
your family jewels that's your balls
manscape just launched their fourth
generation trimmer the lawnmower 4.0
and you heard that 4.0 join over 2
million men worldwide who trust manscape
with the exclusive offer you you get 20
off the free worldwide shipping with
code griffin at manscape.com
all right uh no wiggy today because i
was supposed to do it yesterday so i'm
here right now
doing this uh you know i love wigs
though he's a good good dude
and and make sure you check out his
stuff too he's got posters and he's
and check out the little peep
documentary too on netflix uh he he
recorded like 20 uh 80 percent of that
uh he he was a part of the making of
that so
but anyways guys welcome to riffy
wig griffin whiffin with griffian
and oh hello aaron k thank you and we're
live so if you're listening on
later on audible on uh spotify and all
that kind of stuff you didn't get to
catch it live but thank you still for
listening uh you know i'm still giving
you the
what i give you and and thanks everybody
here for uh being here
um you know uh uh
watching live for you guys in the chat
you know so i i will like i mention you
guys when i can but again i'm a one-man
show today i'm by myself so you have to
forgive me as we uh
go through this so you know i just i i
have to do
i have to do my episodes like i'm even
putting this on twitter right now
you know as as i'm talking to you guys
so
it is what it is so we're uh we're doing
it
um but anyways let's see uh what is
going on this week
man i went to a i went to an oxygen
chamber at uh
next health you guys ever i don't know
if you guys have ever done that before
i've never done anything like that
before
but i was like what is this you know so
it's like apparently there's like a lot
of um
a lot of health benefits um
to to uh being in an oxygen chamber so i
was like you know let me let me
let me let me go check this out because
i'm a part of the next health program so
it's one of these like health places
uh that they um that they
you know they do a lot of like
preventative medicine you know and i'm
all
i'm all about the preventative medicine
you know what i mean so
you know so i go to this place next
health
you know and they have like they have
all this stuff they have infrared
look at like i'm doing a commercial for
them but i'm just saying like i don't
know if you've ever done cryo
it's all these type of things that are
like preventative medicine
techniques that i've tried a lot of them
and it's like it's actually you you
really feel good especially the uh
the um the the the cryo i don't know if
you've ever if you guys have ever done
cryo but you know it's like i don't know
what the temperature is but you stay in
there for like three minutes and when
you get out of there
you feel you're just tingling and you
have all this energy
so make sure you guys check that out but
i want to see let me see if i can find
the
the uh hyperbolic chamber oh look dennis
robin goes late they never put me up
there you know so you know some of these
famous people they got up there but you
know
um you know they do kova testing dude a
lot of stuff there but
wait let me just go back so they do like
like because there's like a benefits i
always wondered like what are the
benefits
of you know hyperbolic
oxygen chambers i mean i wish they can
they just
oh here we go yeah so i i went into one
of these
yeah man you know it's like the oxygen
chamber is a compartment filled with
pressurized air providing oxygen three
times higher than the present in normal
air pressure
you feel like you're in an airplane
though because your ears start to like
you know there's pressure and then you
do have ac in there because it will get
stuffy
and apparently this this is like this
helps you
you know this helps you so it says your
body tissues need an adequate supply of
oxygen to heal itself and
and in turn function properly hyper
hyperbaric oxygen therapy increases the
amount of oxygen
oxygen your blood can carry by filling
the chamber with
enriched oxygen so apparently like this
is great for like when people
you know when they're coming off
surgeries and stuff like that it helps
you heal
you know and you know and all that kind
of stuff so i don't know i don't know if
you guys have ever
you know i don't know if you guys have
ever heard of that or anything like that
once again thanks aaron k for the super
chat i appreciate you guys
and uh yeah if you want to send me if
you have music and theme songs and you
things you want me to use on the podcast
just send it send it my way it's just
just email me at eric
eric griffin.com dude i'll uh i'll get
it
so yeah man so i start in the chamber
and i think i'm gonna start doing it
more
frequently because i'm doing a bunch of
stuff there i get like iv
drips every month i go and get like
immune boost ivs and all this kind of
stuff so i don't know i mean it's not
for everybody because some of it's kind
of pricey so it's like
you know it sucks that like preventative
preventative medical care
sometimes can be costly so you have to
be somebody who has like you know
the ability to do that but i'm sure
there are other cheaper ways to be
healthy but it's like i don't know
i don't you know i don't know if it's
like a accessible to everybody or if
everybody has the knowledge about it
because that's really what's important
right
is like you know how do we take care of
our health like how can we be better
you know it's like it doesn't
necessarily take money we we all have
you know different levels of the things
that we could do but
i i i've talked about this before but i
feel like if i didn't like you know if i
wasn't like doing okay i was man i might
be dying of diabetes or something right
now just because of like
you know eating healthy is expensive in
this damn place like you know we go to
this expensive store
uh air one you know you go get some
cherries or you're gonna get like some
kind of fruit and the [ __ ] is nine
dollars
nine dollars you know nine dollars for
like a you know not even
you know not enough cherries to feed a
family of seven no it's just like this
little thing of cherries for rachel and
i that if we if
we're not paying attention we'll finish
the thing in one night and it's nine
dollars you're like damn
but you can go buy 65 pop pockets for
425
you know like the most unhealthiest food
in the market and in the stores
if all that stuff is um
i don't know i don't know what we're
gonna do about health man this just
sucks dude
last night uh it's funny that i'm what
i'm about to talk about now because we
you talk about health
and then i so last night we ate
i ate pretty good yesterday but you know
sometimes you want to cheat i've been
good my actually i took a test from my
blood sugar
because i was getting towards that
pre-diabetic range
and so i've really been working on that
and uh just took another blood test
and my blood sugar level is below that
now so i'm do i'm
i'm on the right track i'm trending in
the right direction to fight off
diabetes right
but still you have those moments so last
night we went to this donut shop
uh it was late it's this donut shop on
santa monica
uh boulevard it's and they got like the
fanciest donuts and you can order late
from like ubereats and stuff but we were
like we were
we went to go get some sushi and so then
we were like hey let's go to uh
get a donut you know just for some
dessert so you know
i'm i'm about to walk in the store and
in this
sort of home i guess he was a homeless
guy just kind of down on his luck
you know you could just tell you know it
was just like raggedy whatever and he
says to me he goes hey man
he goes can you buy me a donut and a
milk you know
and i'm sitting here and i'm like in my
mind the first thing i think to myself
because this is me i'm a bleeding heart
like that i'm like damn i just
i just dropped a hundred something
dollars on sushi
with my with my chick on a regular night
yeah man
i could get you you know what i mean in
my mind i'm like dude what is it going
to hurt me i don't even need to have
these donuts i'm about to get from
myself what is it going to hurt me to
get this guy
a milk and some donuts you know so i did
you know i was like all right
i got you man so you know i got them and
i think the milk was the most important
thing you needed you know
probably should have gotten a ham
sandwich instead of freaking doughnuts
but
you know i got him a couple donuts in
the milk and i saw him when he opened
the milk and just to look on his face
and just when he drank the milk he was
like oh
you know what i mean i was like grief
man and it's like that ain't even enough
right like i don't even i didn't even
feel good about it you know there are
some people that you know like i gave a
homeless guy two dollars so now i'm good
you know that's my check check me off
for my my gateway to heaven but for me
i just was like damn when he finishes
that
then what it's like we can't save
everybody but it's like what do you do
when you're this kind of person that
like feels like this i just feel
i don't know man i i felt bad
and i i was like when i was driving home
with rachel i was i was starting to tear
up because i was just kind of like
like to to be in that situation it's
like
you know how do we allow you know people
in society to get to this situation
and i just don't have an answer i don't
know what to do i don't know if you've
ever felt like that you guys ever feel
like that you know you
it's like there's some people who just
have no empathy at all you're just kind
of like ah well whatever get out of my
face or i'm not gonna help you
i don't have nothing for you but like i
don't know it's hard for me
like but i feel bad because even if i'm
like
even if i'm like um i have them even if
i give them the money or something i
haven't
i still feel like i know this isn't
enough you're still out on the street or
whatever i don't know man
i just felt i i just had this really
overwhelming emotional feeling and thank
you
thank you ugly goat girl i tried to play
apex legends so she just gave a great
10 super chat i tried to play apex
legends but it just doesn't work
you know like it it did i couldn't even
get a game it was crazy but anyways
so that's my uh feeling on the homeless
man
i don't know that's just something that
happened uh you know but i'm trying to
be healthy
so you know i don't know what you guys
are doing uh being healthy out there so
you know it is what it is uh somebody
asked me what do i think about russell
russ book going to the lakers
um i don't know yet you know honestly i
think i talked about it already but you
know it doesn't matter we're doing this
live uh you know it's a stream of
consciousness
kind of thing going on i just i like to
get my episodes out um
who knows i think if anybody can like
galvanize people to
uh get the best out of them towards a
team effort and a team goal i think it's
lebron james
i think lebron james is going to bring
him into the fold and be like
i think lebron james has enough um
equity
as a superstar as a veteran in the
league as being the best player
uh you know sec first or second play
best player of all time he's right there
in the conversation i think
he has the gravitas to tell russell
westbrook yo
i need you to do this and i think he'll
be like all right i think he's at a
stage in his career at 32 years old
where he's like damn i've done all this
stuff
it's time to win a championship it's
time to like you know make that effort
so
i will see i don't know if there are
games match
i don't think he's uh i don't think he
i don't think he has what do you call it
uh
the the true point guard type skills
that they might need to win a
championship but
you know when you talk about players
that are that great let's see what
happens
you know what i mean let's see what
happens so i do like uh
i do like it i think it's exciting and i
can't wait to see
the nets and lakers playing the
championship that's what we really need
thank you
d merrill appreciate that super chat
thank you very much
um so yeah so that's that so let's talk
a little bit about the olympics
i've been uh watching i haven't been
watching the olympics is really what i'm
trying to say
i haven't been watching the olympics any
any i don't know if you guys have been
watching the olympics but for some
reason
and i think it just has to do with covet
and all this and and being like
all weird i haven't really been paying
attention to it you know
um but there is this one story that
really got to me
uh was this um
you know it was this weight lifter you
know what i mean like
i think there's like a transgender
weight lifter
who's now you know um
you know former former male
and is now
is now a you know female and is a
weightlifter
and i just i'm not trying to be
i don't know man i'm not listen this
this i know
you people might have strong feelings
and it just it turns into like some big
kind of
political discussion so let's let's just
be
as as mellow as we possibly can and just
talk some common sense and just really
you know be
sensitive to the issue and you know
there's a lot of there's a lot of sides
to this they're
you know it's not a black and white
issue what's my favorite word y'all
what's my favorite word
nuanced it is new
honest um so i will say that okay so
i support people who are trying to live
their truth
okay i get that so that's one part of it
like it's not all lumped together
so in terms of saying like people need
to live their truth
they need to like be who they are i
support that okay
that's one side of it all right the
other side of it is now
you're talking about competition is
there a
um advantage where you
have man parts and then now you are
competing
because there's a reason why men and
women don't compete in the same
competitions you know they don't we did
there's there's a reason for that
you know what i mean um so
and and why is that because they're not
physically the same you know men are
physically stronger and faster than
women
so men compete against men and women
compete against women
uh and so they're there you know there
is a
that that's just a fact that's that's
been going on for however how many long
the olympics are going on so now
we have this new thing that's going on
so what do we do about that
like there there is a feeling that it is
unfair that someone who used to be a man
is now competing against women all right
uh
the hormones and what stuff it doesn't
change the muscle structure it doesn't
change
the skeletal structure of someone so
that is an advantage i mean that's just
my i
hey i don't know the science of it it
just seems to me that the common sense
of it should be that
so so then so right now see right now to
me it's because this is so
new in the past 10 years i guess of like
so now in the past 10 years
there's now this all this big movement
for this
the olympics is just behind it's just
behind
so to me you just need new categories
you need men women
and then transgender women
and then the other one transgender men
but
i don't even know if there's a lot of
that happening like are there
former women who are have transitioned
and they're now men
competing against men i don't think so i
don't think so i don't i don't think
that that's gonna be a thing
i don't think that's gonna be a thing uh
but you never know who knows you know
what i mean it depends on
the competition right but for right now
it's really about
i mean the most prevalent thing we think
about is the fact that it's about
men uh who are you former men who are
now women competing against women
so just add a new category i mean that's
all you gotta do
you know what i mean but then i
understand to the feeling of like
those people going hey i'm now a woman
so i you know but that's that's where
that's where it gets tricky
that's the gray area and that's where
you just want to kind of want to go
hey listen you know you already are
admitting that
you were born not the way you wanted to
be so whatever that
you know thing is uh that's giving if
it's giving you an advantage so let's
let not take away from the other people
who are doing this too
you know it's very nuanced and if people
would just talk about it just
very matter-of-factly just plainly with
some compassion and
understanding of either side i think
that we would get past this but what
happens is when you start talking about
something like this
the people that are like super pro
transgender they don't want to hear any
common sense they just think
oh you're anti-anti and i'm not anti if
you're listening to me right now and you
think that you're an
idiot like straight up you're just
you're just want to argue to hear
yourself
argue because you want you that's the
kind of nonsense you want to do and i i
don't
subscribe to that you know that's
problematic when you come at me like
that when i'm
clearly being trying to be as thoughtful
as pro
possible about this but let's not fool
ourselves let's not
sit here and act like this ain't a real
thing it is like this is an issue
and i just think that all parties are
not dealing with it properly and they're
just like
putting it out there you know um
but this is like you know i don't know
i don't want to go too much further into
it uh because again it didn't
you know people get their emotions too
involved in it but come on man you know
it's like
you talk about a former man who is
weightlifting
and are we surprised that they're all
the ones breaking all the female records
and all this kind of stuff it's like
it's like come on you know it's like
this isn't they
they need to really take a good look at
this and go okay let's you know make
another category they compete against
each other and then
that's that but i understand how that
might may seem unfair
or they might realize hey there's
actually not enough or you know it's
like when
or maybe they could do something where
it's like i don't know and i'm just
throwing this out this
this may i'm not saying this is the
answer but i'm just it's in this uh
it's in this vein okay um like when
a uh when women play on a man
on a male or on a golf course you know
they have that like
you know what whatev whatever they have
that thing where it's like okay so the
men
they they tee off from here and then the
women tee off from another spot
maybe they have something like that
going on where it's like you know you're
curbing the times or it's like you know
you you figure out some equation that
you know it's like you know uh you know
a hundred pounds to a um a hundred
pounds to a
um woman uh is you know then you add
you know 25 pounds to a transgender
woman you know so so
you do a math equation and you balance
it out or something i don't know
i don't know what the answer is but this
is a serious problem
um not not that them doing it is a
serious problem it's
how we are going about it and just not
really
planning this out and really talking
about it
you know women's tea thank you i don't
know why i can't you know whatever that
is
i don't know why we can't find a way to
talk about this in that way without it
being such a like
hot button charged issue but you know
it is you know what i mean it is a hot
button charged issue
well i didn't even show you guys so
there's that uh you know on cnn
weightlifter
laurel hubbard becomes first out
transgender woman to compete
at the olympics fails to register at
lyft you know so
you know what i mean i mean it is what
it is
um yeah
i don't know what you guys in the chat
think uh
it's a lot
yeah i mean it's a lot uh but this is
actually a good time to
uh this is this is a good time to uh
go back to our our
sponsor uh manscaped you know
let's talk about manscape um i have
actually used it okay so
you know i'm a hairy dude man look at
these knuckles
okay so and it's like the thing you
always worry about when you're shaving
is just like cutting yourself you
want to make sure that you can you know
what i mean like even if i shave my neck
and i don't shave my knuckles because
if when i do then the next thing you
know they grow back and it really looks
like i'm teen wolf
or teen wolf's grandfather but anyway
you know it's like i'm looking i'm a
hairy dude so you can just imagine what
the rest of my body looks like so you
need that
um you know and it's just like
it's just like and then like if i'm
being even more vulnerable and
open about the the issue it's like you
know
sometimes rachel is like you know what i
want you
i need these balls you know trim down
you know what i mean so you got to go in
there and do it and it's a lot and it's
like a tender area man your balls are
tender you can't just
you can't just go down there just you
know because then like
you don't want the hair being pulled out
or you don't want to cut yourself and i
have done that before i have scraped my
balls
uh trying to do this and then you just
kind of go it's not worth it especially
someone like myself that is a
super hairy so this particular machine
that's especially the new one you know
you know what i mean it just it's
really smooth easy to use they got
wireless charging on it now
um you know what i mean and if you're if
you're a regular if you're a regular
person who doesn't have like a
huge hairy problem but you still want to
be smooth you want to like be a
swimmer then you gotta you know you got
to use
uh the manscape so i do highly recommend
it for you people out there who are like
mid-range hairy super hairy or people
that are like you know just a little bit
and now you then you look like you're
like you know
sleek and ready to go but for you
monster hairy guys you're looking for
something that is smooth and easy to use
and like worry free
about scratching your most tender areas
i suggest you get manscape it's time to
get your
own ball hair and body trimmer with
manscape to make
to make me time the best time and
enhance your confidence with some
knife some nice smooth boys down there
get 20 off guys get 20 off when you use
code griffin
at manscape
get those balls in gear
okay we did it
um so i saw this uh movie
i saw this movie uh luca on disney plus
uh i don't know if you guys have uh
seen the movie but you know what i'm
noticing about a lot of these like
cartoon movies that come out now
a lot of them are just like they're very
much
um what do you call it they seem to be
like
remakes man you know what i mean they
seem to be like
like you know they're they're telling a
story that's already been told
you know what i mean so it's it's uh
it it's in this so this one is it's it's
not little mermaid but it's
it's very little mermaid-ish you know
what i mean so it's like it's in that
realm you know but uh it was it was
actually a really good movie and that
you know so when i watch a movie with
rachel i always count like
how many times is she gonna cry and uh
you know she she did cry at the end
but it's like a fun story you know i do
recommend it if you just like if you
ever like just
sitting around watching cartoons if you
like what you know if you like watching
you know card cause it because
ultimately the new age of cartoons right
now is like telling a good story it's
still about
yeah it's still about you know you know
telling a story of relationships telling
a story of family telling a story of
overcoming something
and and this is very much you know like
that you know so
you know lucas was a sea monster and he
lives you know
under the sea and then there's this
little attack an italian villa it's very
italian too this was like
i think right i don't know if you guys
saw but it was very much like
very ethnic it was very much like
everybody in the movie was like of a
certain thing from this little small
village and it was very
you know it was very cool you know and
then like you know so these
monsters when they come out of the the
ocean and they and they dry off they
they have human form and so
you know they they you know and he's
told don't you go up there because the
land monsters that they call them
you know are going to get you type of
thing so
obviously what he does is he goes you
know and he meets a friend
and then you know he befriends another
another friend and then it's all about
their little
struggle and then his family's trying to
find him and
you know it's a it's a really nice
little fun story you know what i mean
so you know what i mean it's just like i
don't want to rev you know people always
get on me about spoiler alerts
but this is a fun little if you have
kids they'll enjoy it
but this is also like a good couple
movie you just sit and watch it and
enjoy it
enjoy the story enjoy the animation
enjoy the
you know the fun it's just like
sometimes we need this sort of
lighthearted stuff man
and uh luca is one of those movies so i
mean this is just a really quick review
i do
recommend luca so make sure you guys
check that out all right yeah
it was sea creature they called them
right you had sea creatures
yeah yeah coco yeah brother yeah coco uh
ugly goat girl in the chat is talking
about yeah coco is a great one that is
that is one that makes you cry
i mean there are some really good
stories
you know so it's like you know there is
a lot of like
um disney pixar all these companies are
making a strong push to be like hey
we're telling stories and these
characters are not white anymore
or they're not just exclusively white
like every cartoon you see
the all the characters don't have to be
white anymore because there's still
stories you know what i mean
there's still just you know great
stories and you can
you can relate to these stories so once
we
get past that that thing in our head
because we're so
used to everything being a certain way
when it's not that way
we're very much like hey what's going on
here and that's because it's not
normalized yet and we have to like let
the diversity kick in
and let it really sink in that it's okay
it's not taking away from one or giving
more to another
we can start to relate and really see
how we all have something in common
and these these are just ways to to show
that
you know and then you because you can
find something that you
can relate to in any of these kind of
like you know beautiful stories
so just you know just check it out guys
you know what i mean uh this is just one
of those yeah in the realm of like soul
and uh and what was the other one um you
know yeah there's just a lot of uh
you know there's a lot of um
movies out there that are like you know
there are black characters this one was
italian characters and you'll have
latino characters and you'll have
obviously still a lot of white
characters and you know we can all
relate i mean as a person of color
we've had to relate to and find
commonality
in watching tv my whole life you know my
whole life
tv was white you know like i liked
bewitched it was all white people but i
understood the story it was fun
i loved it i dream of genie you know the
partridge family uh
uh you know all those
types of uh the brady bunch and you know
like when i was a kid
there were no those were the options the
the very few black shows that were on tv
you were like okay you enjoyed that um
you know because of what
what that was but like i still was able
to relate i still was able to be like oh
this is just family stories and you know
you enjoy them because you have no other
option to it
but enjoy them so i'm just telling you
like if you're out there
white folks out there don't worry you're
not being nothing's being taken away
from you
you're just seeing another perspective
so you know you're just seeing
other people going through what you go
through and they don't necessarily look
like you but you can still enjoy it you
know
because we've had to enjoy it our whole
lives for a hundred years
for a however long television and tv has
and movies have been going on
we've had to d we've had to look at
white faces our whole lives
and we were like oh this is really funny
you know even in modern times like you
know
even with comedy i've had to look at
like seinfeld and be like oh seinfeld is
like predominantly
always white people on the show and i
still thought it was one of the funniest
shows ever
at the same time martin was on and i'm
like damn martin that show is so funny
you know it's like i don't know we just
have to find a way to
uh just find a way to like find some
positivity in it and it doesn't always
have to be
like in a negative way even if you
coming across i'm not trying to come
across
negative i'm just saying um
just let's find a glass half full part
of
you know watching this diversity you
know
you know what i mean it's like it is
what it is okay so
like i say i do uh highly recommend you
check out
uh luca it's it's a fun movie and by the
way these
they're italian so these people are you
know they're they're they're white
anyway it's not even like they're
i don't even actually i don't even know
i felt like it was italian
just because the accents they were
eating pasta and all this stuff but
it could have been spanish but it's like
i don't know you know what i mean i just
knew it wasn't like american white again
you know what i mean you know you know
what i'm saying if that
if that even uh if that even uh makes
sense to you guys
yeah but oh so let me see what the chat
is you could you know
youtube chat just goes they they go hard
sometimes yeah there were some great
shows like i loved
the jeffersons that was one of my
favorite shows but even that show was
about a black
family living in a white world uh and
how in in the contrast the fish out of
water type of thing so that was great
you know sanford and son
and you know richard pryor had his uh
show for a short time and
it was just a lot of shows but i mean it
wasn't like the most
pro dominant prevalent thing man you
know what i mean
so you know it is what it is okay ugly
go girl
thank you for all these super chats but
come on now
[Laughter]
now i got to play apex legend with her
now
and also speaking of that make sure you
check me out on eric
griffin gaming guys eric griffin gaming
make sure you go to my eric griffin
gaming page
uh to check me out i i i'm on twitch
daily
um you know playing i like
my i mostly play call of duty because i
just absolutely
love that game so if you have a problem
with watching
call of duty i really actually don't
care because it is what it is
but make sure you come check out my page
eric
griffin and gaming and then you can also
look at uh
that uh if you want to get a good gaming
chair i have a really good discount they
don't even offer that discount to anyone
anymore that's just from
my people but you can go and check out a
lot of my videos
i tried to play this new game split gate
but it just wouldn't even load it was a
travesty of justice but you know i gotta
i even have a lot of videos up there if
you want to look at back at my previous
uh victories i have a lot of my solo
victories up there i have a lot of
you know the people like to clip my
channel so make sure you go check out
eric griffin gaming if you're so
inclined to watch gaming if you've never
done it before and it's fun i'm just
there being myself
it's kind of like doing a live podcast
every single day so
make sure you guys if you're into it go
check out eric
griffin gaming
[Applause]
all right okay guys so now i want to get
into
real world advice from a grown ass man
and then we'll finish this out
real world advice from a grown-ass man
okay i did it all right guys so first up
so i'm doing this by myself but i
figured a way to do this so wait i got
to open this up
first up we go here oh man why isn't it
working
god damn it y'all hold up i gotta fix
this
oh there it is there it is there it's
there just there this oh
wait how why is it damn it y'all
okay wait wait wait
okay wait i gotta you're
you're seeing me work on this as i'm
working on it it just is so annoying
this this is not how i wanted it to go
man i gotta reset this
let's do that there we go so let me
wait hold up we're gonna get this right
because i had to unplug my phone to play
the music and i didn't know it was gonna
do this
to the thing but anyways so that's the
first question
up there um
for real world advice from a grown ass
man from this guy on
and i do it on instagram okay so you
guys got me working on it right in front
of you but that's
that's what happens when it's live all
right so this one is seeing a girl for a
little bit
i made a move and she got awkward said
sh said she's
interested okay so this is like
the age-old question that you know
the thing that a lot of guys you know we
we have
trouble with is like thinking just
because somebody's interested
uh that that means however you come at
them
is going to be how they want you to come
at them
that they're going to be you know
comfortable with
the level or the the things that you do
when you're when you're coming at them
and it's that's not always the case
somebody could be interested in you in
one instance
and then you may say something
weird or not weird but maybe you maybe
maybe you're being too upfront maybe
you're being too aggressive or maybe
you're being too
whatever and that person all of a sudden
is like like ooh this is not not where
i'm at
or you know it could even be like you
know somebody's like i'm interested in
you
and then they find out that you're like
an atheist
and then all of a sudden they're like oh
that was weird but to you it's not weird
because that's who you are
so someone could be interested in you
and you could be like yeah i'm a vegan
and you don't like that they eat meat
you know so that could be weird to them
but it doesn't mean that being
uh vegan is weird it just it's not
clicking with that person so
you know when some when you know
someone's interested in you that doesn't
mean like well
that means now i can make a move they're
just saying hey i'm interested to see
where this can go
i think you know guys we go from zero to
60 you know we're like
hey uh i i you're interested in me cool
uh you want to get naked i mean we we're
always ready to go from zero to 60
but you know not everybody's on that
same page or on that same level
so sometimes it takes a second you know
what i mean like like give it a beat
you know what i'm saying like let
somebody uh
let somebody uh you know um uh
take some time to like get to know you a
little bit you know
or it doesn't mean you have to be
talking for eight months i'm just saying
don't be don't be discouraged that you
know you tried to make a move
and then she got awkward because you
don't know her story her thing could be
like when the last guy was too
aggressive or something bad happened or
she's like ooh i don't want to take it
slow and she don't know how to tell you
hey you're going too fast because you
don't want to hurt your feelings because
she does like you i mean you know what i
mean it's nuanced
you know it gets you know you can't just
you can't just think that everyone has
the same experience as you
or everyone thinks the way you think
that's the hardest part about like
interacting with someone and that's the
real important part about getting to
know someone
is just to find out are we on the same
page
because sometimes it's not like a big
gap
sometimes it could be a little small
thing that if you just clear that up
all of a sudden you're like oh now i get
where you're coming from and boom here
we go
you know what i mean pt games thank you
for the super super chat
um so i don't know guys you know what i
mean so this particular guy i just think
that
you know you and you even said seeing a
girl for a little bit
a little bit so you don't know a lot
about you just seen her at all so
it might have got awkward but that
doesn't mean be discouraged by
her response now you need to you need to
know that okay
let me not go that fast uh let me put
her at ease let me make her feel
comfortable i mean that
could be though your approach that would
be my approach
it'd be like okay let's make her
comfortable so then because once
somebody's comfortable
she might be a super freak you know what
i mean sometimes
sometimes somebody knows how they are
and they know that like they go all
in so they make sure they don't go all
in with everybody because they need to
know first so you don't even know what
you're dealing with
so just take some time and see what's
going on with this one all right
so good luck with that
next one another relationship one
talking to this girl at work she got a
man but
seems interested in me should i take a
chance all right so this is just one of
those like
do you want to be a [ __ ] or not
really do you you know
uh you know this is like an ego play and
i totally get it we all
have been there we all feel this kind of
like you know
should i shouldn't i uh um
you know you you're in this situation
where you know you're getting some
attention so you're like yeah then you
feel like you're stealing or you know
stealing this girl this
guy's girl and your ego's all like yeah
she want me
but man i don't know first of all
you're working with her so that's that's
gonna be uncomfortable right away if it
doesn't work out
and just because she's like it and what
has interested me i mean i think a lot
of people you know you're in a
relationship and maybe you're like
you know getting your appetite outside
of outside but you still just want to
eat at home so
i don't know you need to be careful with
that you know because you you she may be
interested in the next thing you know
she's like oh i
you know i didn't mean i was going to go
all the way you know she just
you know people like attention people
like to feel wanted
you know especially women they want to
feel wanted and they want that attention
they want to feel sexy they want to feel
like
yeah you know and just because they want
that feeling it don't mean that they
want to
go all the way with you you know so
and this is just one of those moral
dilemmas it's up to you you know if you
want to be a cheater then you're being a
cheater
you know if you want to be a part of
that i mean i don't think that's going
to end well
i mean it's like you're taking a shot
what are you going what y'all gonna be
in a relationship and you're gonna be
working together after that
that don't seem like an ideal situation
just check yourself and understand what
it really is
you just haven't you just make it an ego
play and you know it's maybe it's time
to like you know
not not do that you know what i mean
all right next one what's the best
advice you have for weight loss i've
been struggling with motivation and
commitment
i think that's what we all are
struggling with motivation
and commitment that's really what it is
so you know you don't want to be in a
situation like myself where
you know you have to take care of your
health because you are you at a health
risk
and that's usually what people wait to
happen you know and it's people
older you know you're like you the
doctor tells you
look if you don't start eating right
you're going to get diabetes and that's
when you go oh [ __ ]
you know so like and then it is and it
doesn't affect people until it affects
people
unfortunately so to try to find some
motivation
uh try to find some motivation for
yourself it's just to think about like
feeling better being healthy and you
don't have to do it like
you don't got to get a bowflex you don't
gotta sometimes like i'm gonna give you
the best advice
that is to start with portion control
with your eating
start there just a simple don't eat as
much as you're eating
you know like if you go to a restaurant
like if you're in a relationship
and you go to a restaurant like share
your food with
you know like maybe you get like a steak
you can share uh
you know you just get the sides you can
share or
you know you split the salad you split
the you know just
take half your food home you know you
don't have to eat everything on your
plate you know
it's that it's really just about that
kind of stuff and then you know you want
to cut back on certain things the bad
things cut back on
sugar i'm not saying cut it completely
out but cut back on
certain things and you will start to see
and make it that's how you start to make
it a pattern
now being healthy and working on your
physique
are two different things so you could
worry about that other
thing later we all want to look good
naked
that's what it's all about you know when
we think about losing weight and
all that stuff we always just go to am i
do i look good
you know but being healthy
being healthy and working on your
physique
being you know that's not the same thing
you could come at them in the same way
but one is a lot more work and sometimes
that ain't even healthy sometimes the
things people do to get a good physique
aren't healthy
things for them you know so you know you
just got to decide
what is your goal you know what's your
real goal here and then work backwards
from that
like if you're a person if you're
sitting out there and be like man i want
a six-pack well there are certain things
you have to do
to get that all right and then
so you need to figure out what is the
end result and work back from that
but if you're just casually just trying
to be like man i i really need to like
because i lost a lot of weight you know
and i know that i'm
i'm going to this thing but a lot of it
had to do with
changing how i ate i just don't eat as
much as i did before
i really have cut back on a lot of
things i don't eat a lot of sugars i
don't put a lot of salt on my food
anymore i
you know i use honey instead of sugar in
my coffee and things like that i
you know i don't drink sodas i don't you
know i stopped drinking
so much iced tea i used to get a lot of
iced tea you know like um
iced tea lemonade mix and you look at
all the sugar content in that so
you know i drink a lot of turmeric now
at night i'd have this turmeric mix
there's no sugar in it
you know it's you know you you'll you'll
find a way you know what i mean like i'm
not
i'm not an expert and i'm still working
on it myself i'm not you know i'm in no
way shape or form like all
you know thank you man uh an ananda
element i appreciate that i'm not mr you
know i'm not jack
lane over here but as a regular person
like yourself
you can look at me and be like oh well
he did it i just did it i'm telling you
i started to get and i also suggest
getting uh one of these meal programs
man green
chef the one the one of my sponsors or
something like that too because that
portion is perfect amount for you
you cook it and and then you eat it and
it's really small you don't have to
worry about having so much
food in your fridge and you know it's
all that kind of stuff man it just
it works great so i i do highly suggest
those type of things you know so
you know it's just
you know it's up to you man you know
but the commitment to it you have to
make it a habit so that's why
i suggest like when you sign up for
something like let's say you sign up for
a meal program
prepay for that [ __ ] for like 10 weeks
so it forces you to use it
because then you'll be wasting money and
then that's how you could build a
pattern
uh and the motivation is find out what
you
want like what is your end goal you just
want to be healthy do you want to just
you know
hey i just want to lose 10 pounds well
you can do that so easily by just
changing your diet start with your diet
okay that's my
biggest advice good luck all right here
we go here's another one
i'm 25 moving out of parents home
relocating to a different state
and starting a new life advice
well this is like hey welcome to the
world man put your big boy pants on
and make it happen if you've been living
at your parents home until you're 25
that tells me they are supportive and
they love you and they will always love
you and they will always be supportive
but it's time for you to leave the
nest and go out and and just do what you
do man
um it's like just stay focused on your
goals you know if you're going to school
or if you have a job
focus on establishing your life so you
know make sure
you're good at work uh wherever your new
place is
make sure you're good there and then you
can start branching out and like meeting
people
a lot of times you meet people at work
you know you meet like because they're
like-minded people because you guys got
the same job
you know start there uh you know keep
yourself healthy like go to the gym
you're gonna meet people there
uh you know what are your activities you
know you're gonna find things man just
like don't be scared
you're you're gonna be fine like i said
if you your parents and your family are
still there for you
and you're just going out and you're
just starting your new life
just stay focused on the things that are
important and work on those things you
know
like i say work get your job and your
work life
up to par and then you know make sure
your home is taken care of and even if
it's even if you're just living in a one
bedroom place or you're renting a room
make sure you're good there and then
you'll start to branch out and establish
what's going on
but stay focused on your life and your
world and everything is going to be
great too
everything everything's going to be fine
for you so don't be afraid of that
just keep keep it going fresh man you're
going to be good
all right let's see what's next stay at
a well-paying job that treats you like
[ __ ]
be miserable or less money and be happy
age-old question right well you know
this is all about how
this is a lot this is so layered nuanced
as i like to say
uh first of all if you if you
let people get to you then you're that's
why you're going to be miserable
like sometimes it's a means to an end so
if you got a high paying job
and you hate the job why do you hate the
job because you don't hate the money
right so whatever you love about that
job focus on that
so because then you don't got to worry
about all these people the things that
are going on here unless you just hate
the job if you just hate the job then
you need to leave that job
but you can't leave that job until you
make sure you are established you know
then you gotta change your lifestyle
like if you have a job it pays you a
certain amount and you're spending all
that money on your lifestyle
then you gotta go all right can i adjust
my lifestyle
make less money and then be happy it's
all about planning
you know it's all it's not as simple as
saying less money and
be happy or not be happy it's all about
planning and how you
respond look your life is this is about
reacting man
you know like you know it ain't about it
ain't about what you do but how you
react to
what's your surroundings so it don't
sound like you have a good reaction to
things that are going on at your job if
your job is just making you so
so miserable that you need to get the
hell out of there or you need to start
going
why am i letting this dumb job get to me
like this
let me change my approach and enjoy some
stuff
because the money's great so it's really
all about your approach
it ain't going it might not just be a
change of venue is gonna make you happy
you know thank you akuro for the i don't
know if i said your name right but thank
you for the oh and that's
some euros too thank you for that i love
the super chat i appreciate it
so you know it's like you know you have
to
you have to decide what makes you happy
you know is the money that the job
provides
and then your life outside of work you
go damn
this makes it worth it because if it's
not worth it there
that's why you're going well what am i
doing this for
making this money because you're
spending all your money on a dumb car
you don't need
are you living in a too expensive place
uh you know you got like
you know spending you you got some
monthly membership to a gym or something
that you don't you know you know you're
wasting that money like
look at your finances and be like is the
money i'm making
making my life worth living over here
because if it's not
that's why you looking at your job like
damn this what am i doing at this
place so start figuring that out balance
that [ __ ] out
balance it out and i think that you'll
start to like feel better about
what you're doing okay
all right i'll be trucking along with
these
here's the next one is it [ __ ] up i
don't have any close friends at age 24
yeah i don't know i don't know if that's
the way
do you think that it's messed up you
know what i mean
is there a reason are you
self-reflecting i think that's what you
should do
i think if you think you don't have any
close relationships in your life you
might want to
consider yourself why why this is one of
these kind of things where i go i
recommend therapy i do i recommend
you know going to some sort of therapy
better help for instance and and uh
just talking to somebody being like what
are your trust issues like
what is it that you why you holding back
why aren't you vulnerable and opening up
like what is it about you make it about
you first
what is it about you that you don't want
to allow people
into your life ask yourself that
you know and at 24 i'm sure it has to do
with your family
you know i'm sure it has to do with your
parents or some kind of thing that
happened
and you know that's like how you
recognize closeness or not maybe you're
not close to your family so you feel
like
if you when you're when you haven't
established that closeness with your
family you don't even know what
close relationships even feel like so
i would say i would say look within
first and that goes for all of us look
within ourselves
and try to figure out why we feel this
way
because it ain't about everybody else
it's something about us
so really looking in the mirror and
going hmm
do i got trust issues um
am i afraid am i uh like you know what's
going on because if you're starting to
feel lonely or if you're starting to
long for
things you see around you then then
trust that feeling that you actually
want that in your life
and go for it you know what i mean then
go for it
um everything's for profit dude
i just saw a dumb comment in the chat
therapy is for profit yeah [ __ ]
yeah everything's for profit okay like
just because just because you make money
on something
it doesn't mean the intention behind it
is bad
okay that's just getting you know you
know
you go to the doctor to get you know
your uh
to take care of your diabetes they get
paid you know what i mean
when you go to any place to make
yourself feel when you go to a massage
therapist
and it helps you relax they get paid
that's the kind of business we're in
it's like you have to you have to stop
questioning intentions just because you
know
that that's not a reason to question the
intentions all right it's like it's like
get the [ __ ] out of here with your
nonsense all right anyways
sorry guys sometimes there's an idiot
and i have to like
attack because you that kind of thinking
is narrow-minded and frankly stupid
all right you know you don't want to be
a glass-half-empty person
you want to be like yes in each
individual case
there could be somebody that's taking
advantage of a system and
screw that person but don't assume
everybody is like that just because you
have a warped view of the world
all right so and that goes for this guy
too
you know what i mean look within
yourself and
figure out what it is about
you that you know
you want to you know why you're closed
off
then maybe you'll start to open up and
the next thing you know
boom you're you're out there in the
world doing it
okay all right we only got a couple more
i think this is the last one my wife is
over the top
paranoid about kovitt do i live by her
covet rules or rebel and cause a huge
rift
well i mean happy life happy wife right
but also just being sensitive to
you know whatever it is man it's like
you know it's all anecdotal when it
comes to lycovic you know there are
people
that like they have had some close loved
ones die
so that is making them way more cautious
about things
so you don't want to be in a situat like
in instead you don't want to be in a
situation
where you know you're fighting
over like ideology you know you might
want to talk
sit her down and talk to her about this
you might want to be like hey
you know do some research that's that'll
help you know
look at the numbers uh you know you
might want to go to your doctor and talk
to your doctor hey
you need to put her at ease you need to
make her feel better because there's a
lot of misinformation out there so
and it sounds to me like she's gotten a
hold of that misinformation or you want
to find out
why she feels the way she feels so you
can put her at ease make her more
comfortable
but you don't want to fight with her
because that ain't gonna help [ __ ] like
do not fight with her about this but at
the same time you don't want to just
like cave either because
you know it's not helpful to either one
of you either because especially if
you're
if you know hey this is too much we
don't need to do this
you need to find a way to sensitively to
uh
sensitively and thoughtfully explained
to her hey
you know what i think at home we're good
let's just make sure we clean off our
counters make sure when we come in the
house we wash our hands you know what i
mean
there are things you could do to put her
at ease to make her feel better trust
is earned it's not given all right trust
is earned it's not
given okay guys
um yeah that was fun
i feel like we uh i feel like we i feel
like we did the damn thing here at uh
riffin with griffin and i you know i
appreciate all you guys
you know listening and and coming here
and
being a part of this and uh you know
and uh coming every week you know um
like i say make sure you check out my
gaming channel uh we are i'm gaming
every single day i actually got to go do
another podcast right now and when i get
back from that i'm gonna
get on a game and that's that eric
griffin gaming so make sure you guys
check that out
but i appreciate you guys for being here
i appreciate you guys for
supporting me i like all the super chats
today
thank you very much and please like let
me know in the comments if you like
because i did a bonus live episode
you know a few date on thursday if you
want me to do keep doing bonus live
episodes along with this main episode uh
because i'm having more guests because i
think what i'm going to do is when i
have a guest in the week i will do a
solo bonus episode to just more content
and keep it out there
uh but i do really do appreciate all you
guys
and shout out to jimmy knives right now
in my chat he's my
new twitch videographer and he's
he's put out he's put together some
really funny videos
of my content so you can check that out
at eric griffin
gaming eric griffin gaming on youtube
you know i put up those videos there so
make sure you guys check that out
fun stuff going on over there at eric
griffin gaming on youtube so please
check that out
um and thanks for coming to
uh riffing with griffin and everybody i
will see you
next week